[Music]
oh
what is up
kiddos mainly adults no kids are less
than this what's happening man it is
monday monday morning
april 18th it is monday morning here in
beautiful calabasas california
what's going on everybody good good
weekend how was your easter good easter
good good
is the lord's day your boy had to work
on the lord's day i have a strict policy
in my life where i don't work on sundays
never have
never ever want to work on sundays
but
but
i uh i got a
i got approached by uh
volkanovsky the
champion of the ufc you guys know
alexander volkonovsky the great his uh
team was out here he's on a little press
store
and uh he flew from australia and then
obviously had his fight but then he uh
was in new york he's on schultzy's show
i think ariel and some other big shows
out there in new york then he came to la
and they hit me up and uh they said man
we'd love to do a food truck oh i'm a
huge fan of volkanovsky we got to make
it happen
but your boy was on tour in phoenix
shout out to phoenix one of my favorite
venues
stand up live also shout out to
um
jt's wings my favorite chicken wings on
this planet earth
it's a little it's like a it looks like
it looks just a normal bar but they have
a kitchen out the back and there's it is
packed in there men so shout out to the
owners of jt's they like kind of roped
off a little spot for for me and the
thick boy crew and we ate so many
chicken wings i felt bad
and then uh also uh my boy
giannis papas was on there he came
through and he ate some chicken wings
and we were able to chat it up
and my boy kevin bay set it all up so
shout out to jt's wings man best wings
on planet earth happens to be in phoenix
i think it's right outside like uh
paradise valley or something like that
but
i'm telling you your boy here is thick
david lucas we call him the wingmaster
nope david in every single city hits up
the best wing spot and gets it to the
airbnb
dude's thick man
dave's thick okay thick fake david knows
this he's the roast master and he's the
thickest roast mash you've ever seen and
he knows wings so i was nervous to bring
him here and uh you know because he's
pretty critical that's him singing
country music if you click on the middle
one the middle yeah
did you know he loves country music no
me and him are basically brothers now
sam hunt follows him oh
we're just jamming out to some freaking
country i didn't know he liked country
when we played it i was like whoa what
do we have here
but uh
yeah he's the wing master and he
absolutely loved these wings man he
freaking loved him thank god because if
he goes bad on would not be good for
jt's wings but he loved him so we're
good
so long story short i uh
you know i i
volkanovsky was i think he's he's
leaving uh sunday night his flight back
to australia which is the longest flight
in the world um
he leaves uh he was leaving
uh sunday night at 11 p.m
so as much as i hate to do especially on
easter sunday flying back from phoenix
all right you gonna do sunday and he's
like yeah we'll make it happen before we
leave i'm like oh let me try and find a
food truck and get the crew together you
know it's a holiday so you can't ask you
know you can't
expect everybody to work on a sunday but
we got a little makeshift crew we got it
together
the uh food truck that came along was
not a food truck it was an el camino an
old-school el camino some of the best
food is uh
uh
rapas they call them
it's venezuelan basically like uh think
of it as like a uh venezuelan like
gordita taco like it's a real thick
tortilla shell
and then he puts like tinga orca natara
in it and it's fantastic it was
delicious thank god cause i know
volkanovsky wanted good food so thank
god it was good food
um so we did that
and then they know i'm on carnivore you
see on the show i definitely eat that uh
fancy gordita but they made me a rib eye
that he um
he does like just pepper and salt and he
puts it in some like uh
like liquid and lets it soak for 24
hours so all the salt and pepper soak
into the meat and then he says when you
grill it the way he does it i don't know
what solution he puts in it brings all
the flavor out of the meat to the to the
surface dude
nazos it was such a good freaking steak
so that was my easter sunday i spent
with volkanovsky some other kids too i
spent the kiddos too because i landed
and then we did the whole easter bunny
thing
and uh they were pretty crunk about the
the easter bunny
this guy who's weird that he's not
feeling this rabbit but he's literally
making sure contact and smiling stop
pushing this narrative
imagine writing that
where'd he go tyler imagine writing that
um
yeah those rabbits are freaking creepy
man but uh yeah volkanovsky dude the
the food truck will come out this week
we're hoping for thursday the team is
grinding to get this food truck out but
one of my favorite food trucks man he
said and we've never met we've never met
and you know some guys most fighters i
have some sort of relationship with or
we've talked or some i've fought on the
same card with and so there's a
relationship there and then some i've
never met before and it can be a little
awkward or it's a little stiff you know
and they're just doing your
run-of-the-mill you know like you know
for my next fight i want and you know
it's not really what i do i just want a
conversation but volkanovsky right away
i and i i accredited to this
he
grew up uh with team sports you know he
grew up doing greco-roman wrestling i
think he was a gold medal winner some
[ __ ] he's a monster but he grew up
playing rugby so he's always on the
rugby team played semi-pro was like the
mvp of the league just a monster but
you're around that so
you know when guys come from that
background you know we have a common
bond it's like you know just bros and
dude he offline if you wanna hear him
talk about his rugby like shenanigans
listen to flagrant two with andrew
schultz and volkanovsky he talks about
they called a bubbler
now we all know that when bros get
together they get wild especially
you know the most wild i've ever heard
of stories that i've heard of and
personally know would be nhl hockey
players nobody's more wild than nhl
hockey players when they get together
and boys are wild
mlb can be a little wild but you know a
lot of them are a little subdued
nfl sure you have some of them ufc not i
mean yeah but it's also it's not a team
sport
nobody gets more wild than australian
rugby players at a high with a high
level
you'll hear it on shoulder show we talk
about a little i reference it a little
bit you know because schultz already did
it so i don't want to dive too much into
it but
they they called a bubbler
what a bubbler is is when you pee into
your own mouth
yeah they do it like all the time
they do a shoei where you just piss in
the shoe and somebody else drinks it
there's no way i'm telling him
he kept calling a bubbler that's so
funny we wrapped the show i don't think
we're filming this i go then that's a
that's a wrap for the bubbler boys like
hey
yeah they get wild man yeah but yeah he
was he was [ __ ] good you hear you
know i talked to my you know tell him he
was the original thick boy because uh he
used to be 240 pounds and he's like dude
i was in 240. he goes i think you and
rogan started that rumor you guys were
brought me up
and he's like and then the internet just
ran with us too for he said i was in two
four days two fourteen i was like still
would he five five five four
two fifteen
or two fourteen to be exact that's
nutzos dude
and he was like yeah but for rugby it
was impossible to tackle he's like a
little armadillo just [ __ ] run down
the field like a baby rhino with the
ball in his mouth good luck tackling
that kid
but yeah he's great man his manager ash
you know i deal with managers and agents
all the time in this line of work oh man
spring is almost here the sun is popping
out here in l.a and when that sun's
popping i worry about my lawn man listen
as a dad i've never been more invested
in my lawn there's nothing like flexing
on your neighbors when you got a green
lawn dude when you have the best lawn in
the neighborhood
the mother dads are jealous man they're
jealous but i'm i'm let you on a little
secret right now everyone's like dude
how's your lawn so green how the fish is
popping like jumanji right now what are
we doing here you know what you know
what my secret is it's sunday yep yep
sunday get your lawn growing and helps
keep it healthy all season long and if
you've got kids like i do and you're
worried about the chemicals and all that
and you're doing whatever it takes by
any means necessary to keep your lawn
looking green get rid of that stuff man
traditional lawn care lays down 90
million pounds of pesticides each year
we don't need that you need with your
kids running around dogs cats kangaroos
whatever you got sunday is different
they're on a mission to change how
people care for their yards and you
don't need those chemicals man you don't
need them sunday is completely different
you don't have to choose between having
a beautiful
yard and keeping your family out of
harm's way we got it all man all right
sunday can help you grow a beautiful
lawn and you're gonna flex on these
other dads in the neighborhood without
the guesswork or the nasty chemicals all
right they have a custom plan includes
fertilizer and everything you need to
easily care for your lawn and with
ingredients like seaweed iron molasses
you can feel good with the kids and pets
running around all you have to do is
visit getsunday.com put in your address
and their lawn specialist does the rest
they then use the soil and climate data
to create a personal nutrient plan
delivered to your door when you need it
and this is what's best about them you
just attach the ready to use pouch to
the garden hose and spray away it takes
15 minutes to it's relaxing i enjoy
doing it because i know my lawn's gonna
be pop and daddy best of all this stuff
actually works take it from a boy here i
got the best lawn in my zip code thanks
to sunday all right and sunday is
offering you dads out there 20 off full
season plans are just 129 buckaroos it's
a great deal you get 20 off at checkout
when you visit get sunday
getsunday.com
that's getsunday.com
that's 20 off your custom plan at
getsunday.com
shop good luck out there with your lawns
daddies
if there's one thing every fighter knows
is that you're never going to step in
the ring unless you're 100 prepared man
you always got to watch out for that
sucker punch listen the same applies
with investing yeah that's right you can
get sucker punch man like if you
invested heavily in stock and crypto you
got sucker punched but not your boy here
that's because i got masterworks in my
corner that's right they help normal
guys like me that don't really have a
clue what they're doing invest their
money and they help me diversify their
portfolio all right with blue chip art
from masters like picasso monet basquiat
diversify with art isn't new all right
the ultra wealthy have done it for
centuries
the ultra wealthy sun when you realize
blue chip art prices outpace the sp 500
by 164 percent for the last 25 years
almost 125 years that'd be forever ago
uh for the last 25 years it makes
perfect sense i'm a gantic fan of
masterworks which is why i'm teaming up
with them join over
330 000 members get priory access to
massworks with this link go to
masterworks dot art
shop s-c-h-a-u-b that's masterworks dot
art slash shop see important disclosure
that mathworks dot io slash disclaimer
dude as far as likes just being creative
smart with his guys he doesn't come from
a traditional
agent background or manager background
he was
friends like he's close came up with all
of them izzy him he helps hooker uh
kayak france they have just this monster
team out there and he's really he's just
their boy who looks out for him turned
in his manager and dude
he's a beast smart smart dude that's
what you need man these regular agents
don't know how to figure this out they
really don't know what to do then you
get your you know your your venom
sponsorship and the harley davidson and
toyo tires from the ufc sure but you
need somebody
that is kind of a little outside of that
lane to really grow your brand and you
look what he's done with izzy granted
izzy is a unicorn checks all boxes and
he's interesting and he has so many
layers to him he actually has a
documentary coming out which i can't
wait for which you know ash the manager
just set up and they've been filming
them for
years dude they have all this footage
which can be lit as [ __ ]
but you know you got a guy outside the
box like think about just even his pr
that he did in north america because
remember when volkanovsky became
champion and like had these big breakout
fights windmill pandemic he's an
australian man so you're not going
anywhere you got a quarantine for two
weeks get back to australia with your
family they couldn't leave the house
like north korea over there they can do
[ __ ] so for him he wasn't able to
kind of build his brand being the
champion with the belt and doing all
that [ __ ] so
he decided to capitalize on it this time
the thing about this week type of dude
ashes
so you can do your traditional
interviews espn
you know you name any of those you know
kind of suits all the espn shows you
know all that stuff the the network tv
and it's fun and you know those are
black and white they check the box and
you know but those people are they're
kind of aware of you
but then to go on flagrant two with
schultzy who chelsea has a relationship
with ashton is the ufc and to come on my
show and just do these podcasts which
have these you know large fan bases who
they're going to love voclanofsky
they're going to love them but
your traditional agent and manager
they're not going to think of that man
they're gonna call because
what gets them their 10 percent or how
much they're take robbing from these
poor fighters you know they're going hey
man we got your espn you oh that's
cooperative espn but for ash go dude
you're doing flagrant you're doing shop
show you know you're doing all these
shows which
you know i mean if ufc call me up do
whatever they want to do
whoever they have would be my life would
be so much easier instead of going
through the fighter or the manager but
that's not my relationship with them i
have to
usually reach out or they reach out to
me just
organically the fighters do hey i'm in
la man i'd love to do food truck all
right let me try and find food truck
let's do it dude and that's why you saw
like cleo around you who have a personal
relationship with used to be training
partners bobby green he's been trying to
get on for i don't know six years
but because the show time it didn't work
out you know because when i was showtime
i didn't have a lot of say in a lot of
it i just didn't handle it so now that i
do it's a different animal so now it's
like i'm getting guys on that i want i'm
not getting guys on just for ratings or
to check this box or make sure i'm
covering this i'm getting guys on who i
either
would love to have on because we have a
personal connection or i've told them
they could come on years ago
or i just certain guys i just want like
volkanovsky
one i would say there's maybe five guys
in the ufc i'd work a sunday for
volkanovsky is one of them and thank god
he's one of my girls favorite fighters
too because i landed at 11 00 11 a.m
and she was like all right we're i see
you know i flew into burbank so i'm
about 35 minutes uh from burbank so i
get home around 11 30. say yeah the kids
are antsy they're ready to go for you
dressed up as the you know you're gonna
dress up as the easter bunny hide the
eggs
yeah i get home you know that the kids
can't know i sneak in i put on the
[ __ ] bunny outfit and i've hide all
the goddamn eggs hit them too well
and you know they're [ __ ] six and two
what are you doing dude so that took
forever in the hot sun i'm sweating my
ass off in this rabbit suit
so i do that and i go babe i gotta work
later she's like on a sunday easter
sunday too easter sunday dude try
getting a crew together on e i forgot
you know i'm not the most religious guy
easter sunny to me listen if you're
religious god bless you man i'm jealous
of you um
but you know easter sunday for me is
about the kids about you know for them
it's the rabbit
and
hiding chocolates and eggs and [ __ ]
peeps and all that [ __ ] and then having
a good you know lunch which we had but i
just told my grandma i got to work
at four she's like what
i was like hey i got a food truck she's
like who the [ __ ] is shooting on a
sunday like i know they're freaking
savages i said but it is volkanovsky she
goes ooh do you want me to make him a
plate
[Music]
goddamn girl
put your tits away you know what i'm
saying
he lives in australia good luck
but uh yeah it'll drop this week it's
one of my favorite ones this whole crew
is good man
the whole crew they had you know they
got hooker out there they had you know
that they kind of and they all not that
they all train either tyson pedro and ty
to avos and hooker and
izzy and kaiker of france who's you know
i think is going to get a title shot and
they're just these monsters men
you look at you know the doors that izzy
has opened for everyone it's just nuts
man there's so many layers to izzy you
see i bring it up to volkanovsky i feel
like kim
and izzy are kind of in the same lane as
far as
they you know they both want to be
really active but in their divisions you
know at middleweight in 145 so 185 and
45.
they've kind of beat the who's who so
we're waiting for this kind of new blood
to come along or somebody go on a streak
and they got to wait for that so they're
kind of at the mercy of the division
and for volkanovsky there's obviously
you know i think
and you'll see it on food truck someone
can get tuned in but i think he has you
know four options that he can can roll
with
and you also see you know i talked about
lightweight so on the fight companion
brian goes i'd like to see him go to
lightweight and i light brian up you
know i just light him up and i apologize
to brian foodtruck and i apologize to
volkanovsky but i told volkanovsky
because you know he was aware of it
and i just said
you know he fought at lightweight wealth
rate and even middleweight but remember
he used to be a bigger guy and he cut
all this weight now he's you know the
number two pound-for-pound guy in the
world
that's what's he's making the right
decisions
but when he fought at lightweight or
welterweight and middleweight
it wasn't in the ufc so i don't care
that's why i said it's no disrespect i'm
sure those leagues were great and you
know good opponents but it's not the ufc
and lightweight in the ufc
is the hardest division in the world so
for you to go from what you're doing now
to there
to me seems like a big jump and i said
but i will say this you're bigger than i
thought i'll give you that you're bigger
i thought his hands are
way bigger than mine
his dick must be massive dude it must be
like a [ __ ] molson's [ __ ]
bear can dude it's just this giant dick
too i'm sure i don't know for a fact but
i'm sure bubbler is easy for him to do
as well i'm saying but his hands are
thick dude like a [ __ ]
kangaroo on hgh it's [ __ ] his hands
are huge and he's talking i'm just
staring at his hands like goddamn
so he was like no i hear the argument
he's like and that's fair because it's
not the ufc he's like in lightweight you
know is a stretch of ufc and when guys
go up
he goes i see the concern he goes but
you gotta realize even at 45 i'm always
the shorter guy but he goes but i'm
always the strongest guy
he was in in my training camps i don't
really train with lightweights and below
never i don't train with any
lightweights i train with all
lightweight like i'm sorry i don't i
train with he doesn't train with any
other 45ers definitely not 35 or sure as
[ __ ] not 120 fibers his entire camp
consists of 55 and up he only goes with
55 or 70s 80 fibers even light
heavyweights because we do wall work we
do wrestling
and he said it's because of my strength
and power that i can only get to work
with them and he goes and i'm not you
know throwing any shade on those guys
but i definitely carry my own with those
higher weights and goes and i think one
of the reasons
why i have the strength and i'm built
like this because i did used to be 214
pounds so my bone structure and the you
know the tendons in my muscle is
stronger than almost everybody well
let's be honest i'll say it for him he's
the strongest at 145. so he's like so
for lightweight for me you know i think
people always talk about you know the
the strength different and the power
difference
it's not going to be a problem for me
he's like i could easily do it man i
said yeah but the the other variable
you're leaving out is a size difference
and said in your butt your boy izzy
learned that unfortunately i wanted to
beat frickin john so bad dude to get to
the jon jones fight that had been great
for everybody involved me as far as this
show the ufc jon jones izzy had been one
of the greatest stories ever [ __ ]
happening
sports period but it didn't work out you
know he he shot for the moon land on the
stars still dominating at middleweight
and doesn't have any really opponents
there cannon ears can be a great fight
decaying as tough as [ __ ] you fight the
heavyweight you know so that's an
interesting fight for sure but outside
that there's not a lot going on there
that's why they're building up that guy
who beat him in glory he's fighting sean
strickland which is a tough [ __ ]
fight for him but if he gets past that
he still would have to get past a
whitaker or uh the tory or you know some
of these some of these monsters that are
you know one through five just because
you beat strickland i don't think
they're just catapult them to the title
shot i don't think it works like that so
and i
i think strickland is an underdog in
that which i'm surprised by i'm very
surprised by that
i think i'm right on that i should chin
but yeah i do think strickland's a a a
dog in that which is
surprising to me i i i think strickland
wins that fight it's not i'm not a
fan of that guy
i just think it's it's a lot
but uh
the point is is he was saying you know
well i know you talk about size oh so
he's a minus 175.
oh well why say minus 70 there now
let's go to i don't know if draftkings
have looked you say so on march 29th
strickland opened up as a slight
underdog plus 150.
there you go against a minus 175 for
pierre
yeah
that's flipped a little bit so i don't
see even but you know i don't see it
so now pierre is a plus 150.
strickland opens at plus 150 betting on
it according to best fight odds
uh
trigonometre opens as a plus 150 betting
underdog according to draftkings against
a minus 175 piera which is surprising to
me just the amount of work that
strickland does and he you know he's a
wild boy wild card tough tough to
you know
not bank on him getting that win there
but um
the point is is wilkanowski was like i
don't think size is going to be an issue
for me
i said sure you want to fight at you
know lightweight and he went through
some of the guys and
i think he said what makes the most
sense for him is conor at 55
because he's beat all the legends at 45
wants to be the king of 45 and i was
like conor's never making 45. he's like
i know so i'll meet him at lightweight
if he'll do it so i'll meet him at 55
which is a great [ __ ] fight
for connor that's a no-brainer fighting
the champ at 45 at 55
you know conor's a problem at 55. i know
he hasn't got a ton of wins there but
he's still a [ __ ] monster you know
remember when he was a double champ
45-55 we beat eddie alvarez so i think
55 is by far the best
weight class for conor mcgregor if
you're conor fan you're foaming at the
dick your irish dick is foaming right
now he's counting at 55 is a beast 70's
a little dicey you know he's big right
now but i think 55 would be a good home
for him so him versus volkswagenowski an
insane fight because he goes because i'm
going to ask you what's the biggest
fight i could do at light weight on
conor mcgregor easily all day there's
history there with you guys at 45 you
know he's not coming to 45 so you can
see him at 55 it's your first fight at
55 that's going to sell the most tickets
outside that max holloway a trilogy with
max holloway at 45
and then there's also henry suhuta out
there
he made a good point though i'll shut up
about the food truck after this but he
uh he made a good point he goes i don't
take cehuto serious not that he's not a
great fighter but when he was asking for
the fight when korean zombies stepped up
and he was giving me [ __ ] for taking the
korean zombie he was remember
he was like i'll do it remember he's not
in the usada testing pool at the time
you got to be in for six months that
wasn't even an option he's like so
that's all clout and [ __ ] talk and i get
he's doing it for the brand and to build
his profile he's like but
i can't even entertain it he's not even
a valuable option a
viable option it's not happening he's
not in the testing pool yeah yeah makes
sense
so we'll see man
we'll see but yeah you guys enjoy that
food truck if i had to bet i would
imagine it comes out uh
thursday and the squads are driving down
to san diego tomorrow for a very special
guest on food truck
so see man but shout out to volkanovsky
ash his whole team man you guys are
[ __ ] great keep crushing it uh you
had some fights this weekend you had
some fights this weekend
you know like i told you the card wasn't
going to blow your freaking hair back
but you did have an important fight in
the welterweight division on ufc fight
nine on saturday
my boy i love muhammad too he's a great
commentator a good podcaster just all
around smart dude [ __ ] hell of a
fighter man
because you remember this is a rematch
with sente luke knocked him out in
mesquite garden the first time so
they've both been on this win streak
and i think the ufc is like right
one of these guys is is we have to take
the other out we gotta figure this out
so they made him fight i thought and
luke was the favorite and i thought that
was you know pretty appropriate and
muhammad ended up beating them kind of
you know handle them you know the judges
i think got it right 49 46
48 47 i didn't see that you know but uh
49 46 makes sense for for me there so
muhammad throws his freaking he has a
big old head man head like a rottweiler
as a welterweight he has that pitbull
head so he throws his big head into the
the pool to get the next shot at kumar
usman you know i don't know if that's
next for him i think there's some other
stuff going on with usman um he wants to
fight in july
so we'll see what happens there and yes
it has to get through leon edwards i
don't think muhammad's going to wait i
also don't think ufc guaranteed matado's
shot so we'll see what happens but huge
win for muhammad huge for the division
and uh you know the
the cue for the welterweight shot gets a
little more
clear now that muhammad took out vicente
luke because there was argument luke
versus kemar usman that you know he was
on food truck and that's the fight that
he wanted or he wanted nate diaz
but now that he's lost to muhammad that
he kind of takes a step back there so
it's pretty clear man they have hamzad
at three now okay we're at four that
makes sense luke was at five so uh
muhammad to jump up to five
i mean muhammad burns a fantastic fight
a big great fight
so we'll see and if hamza wants to stay
active if they can't figure out their
kobe commenting because i think
colby a
um he wants to be paid the same as
mosvidal because we're negotiating his
contract so i told you guys you know
don't
jump to conclusions yet i know dana goes
yeah kobe versus hamzat if he were to
beat gilbert burns on abc
all for it take my money even though i
don't have to pay for it take my money
but uh the caveat there is colby
covington wants to be paid the same as
moswell he doesn't think should be paid
less you know he's he's he beat him
he beat him and i i do think uh colby
deserves that so they got to figure that
out and i don't know if they can figure
that out in time for that abc card which
i don't know when that is
but you know
going back to uh camaro usman
you know again but if hamza wants to
stay active muhammad's not a bad option
he's right there i'm not mad at that
ufc on abc i need to have a schedule
june 18th june 18th
boy they better get going with colby's
contract i'm sure they're trying to
figure out right now
they're calling it fight night huh
dude colby for tom's out on that would
be mind-blowing
you might see hanzo vs uh muhammad on
there though too
depend how long muhammad gets suspended
for
that'd be interesting
really interesting
uh but that abc is all good that's in
june but july 2nd
you have the big pay-per-view the ufc
always goes
balls out for the the summer july 2nd
card they have the ufc expo you know
kovid has shut that down but now it's
back so if ufc's can go all out on that
july 2nd card
um
yeah there it is ufc 276
and i've been telling you guys for quite
some time that they're going to do jon
jones stipe well guess what
jon jones and steve both have contracts
for july 2nd
holler at your boy
the number one fight i want to see in
the ufc could potentially be going down
pretty i think john has signed and
they're just waiting on steep bay
interesting
steve base put on i was talking dc he
said stipe put on weight he spawned like
15 pounds of solid muscle he's ready to
go
stipe jon jones july 2nd
what for the summer card daddy we're all
getting tan
what
dude
a nice cold blue moon and of jon jones
stipe fight by the pool
[ __ ] dude
tell me if
i was president ufc for one day like i
can make you know a few fights the first
one i make is stipe jon jones
it's the only fight that i want
this is dana talking about i didn't see
this him confirming it yeah not
confirming he says listen people have
been talking about how awesome this card
is i was telling somebody the other day
our lineup for this summer is incredible
that makes my day card dana
i'm hoping that jon jones is gonna be
part of this lineup uh part of that
lineup this summer
uh then tmz followed up and asked if
this meant we could see john take on
francis or steve bay and the and fans of
the former champ out of ohio are going
to be excited he goes yeah stevia makes
sense
yeah weird questions say francis in the
summer right tmz because you don't you
don't know the game huh uh this is what
i was talking about if you have an agent
and put you on tv now throw out tmz i
like timzy not throwing shade on them
but you know they're not balls deep in
the game so like well what's up with
francis
hey man
it's surgery on his goddamn knees out to
next year he's not in the conversation
but stipe is one of the greatest ever do
it
you have a great versus a great goat
versus a goat take my money
ufc 276. goats and just have those two
on the poster i wonder what they they
don't have anybody on the rest of the
card right no nothing in there
because they're trying to do camaro leon
edwards on that too
now if i'm the ufc for ufc 276
and i want some shenanigans i mean i
want this thing to
pop right i want it i want pop pop i
want a bubbler in my mouth
a bubbler that's a again that's
australian term for pissing your mouth
which is pretty fantastic but if i want
a bubbler i want that bubbler card
i'm going you could call it ufc 276
bubbler boys
but what i would do for a bubbler of an
event is i'd put izzy on there against
uh cannon air
in the co-main event
and you're gonna have non-stop
sound bites because john and izzy have
to be around each other during press
and that just builds that drum up even
more
god dang
you're welcome
god i hope that happens steve based on
the contract dude i don't ask for much
man still love you i just want that
fight to happen it's such a good fight
and the countdown john coming back
no one gets me excited
i shouldn't say no one when conor were
in this prime
i was crunk as [ __ ] that was the most
excited i've been for fight cards
close second is jon jones not when he's
that light heavyweight like just kind of
coasting and beating these young lions
but i'm talking went to john versus
vitor leoto or chael sonin or dc or
augustus finn and now he's that
heavyweight and he's motivated he's
bigger than ever john's first time at
heavyweight main event summer card
stipe
arguably the best heavyweight to ever
[ __ ] fight in the ufc
what
say
what god it'd be [ __ ] lit
that'd be a bubbler event boys
all right jim what else you got
uh there's one more fight card over the
weekend
i know my boy aj mckee
lost the patricio pitbull patricio got
his belt back i don't know did you watch
your chin i watched the highlights and
then i also read the play-by-play uh-huh
the majority of people scored it for
patricki really yeah picture show
whatever yeah obviously i'm gonna be
biased because i love aj but we'll see
what's interesting about this is even
before the fight
the the belter has been trying to resign
aj i think he has like yeah two fights
left on his contract so trying to resign
him right obviously he kind of hurts him
a little bit in negotiations now he lost
the belt but that's whatever it's a
close fight i'm sure they'll do a
trilogy fight before he leaves beltor
but he was talking about in interviews
and it makes i mean i don't think it's
you know a black guy to bellator no pun
intended but i think
um you know he was like you know my goal
since i was a kid i grew up watching the
ufc i'll be ufc champion that's my goal
which is interesting when you're he said
he's gonna get there
yeah he was like it's in you know it's
bound to happen on bfc champion so
clearly his eyes
are on the prize for ufc belt
which makes sense man everyone wants to
pretend you know this elephant in the
room that
these other league there's no shade on
these other [ __ ] leagues but
the ufc is the coca-cola of mixed
martial arts the ufc is the nfl of mixed
martial arts it's just what it is
especially
people say well just in america not
really kind of all over man
those young kids in china and africa and
brazil don't grow up going i want to be
bellator champ or i want to be insert
whatever other league champ your goal is
to be ufc champ so for aj who has a deep
history
in freaking um
you know mixed martial arts
uh grew up and he was around rampage
during his run and all that stuff and
rampage was jammed he saw the belt so he
said that was a big influence on him you
know i just think it's interesting he's
doing it now during negotiations maybe
it's a tactic for him to be like hey i
can jump ship i want to go to the ufc so
unless you guys pay me he also said you
know the first time when he beat pitbull
it was the tournament he won a million
dollars he's like i don't be paid less
than a million dollars man
so we'll see you know i you know i don't
know if the belt is going to pay a
million dollars per fight i don't know
the ufc sure as [ __ ] ain't
they're just not yeah
now if you get to be champ you make a
mill it's gonna take some work
uh then on fortune the the nem cough and
uh nimkov and uh corey anderson fights
was stopped uh a no contest frank trigg
was the ref there shout out to frank
trigg a legend
um there's a no contest the bummer about
that is if it went five more seconds
when the fourth round it would have went
to a judge's decision and cory answered
would have won the fight that's why he
seemed so frustrating throws the water
bottle
so if they could just let it go on just
another five seconds we have a clear
winner in the light heavyweight and it's
corey anderson
cranston's a [ __ ] bad man pajama dude
and i'll see aaron pico doing the
goddamn thing re-signing with bellator
continues just
freaking
take
well this was a catway at 150 but at 45
he's taking the division over by storm
he's stepping into his
you know i'd say big shoes i come the
close thing as far as a prospect of
lebron james in mma that we've had i'm
telling you man he you know he had some
hype there where i think maybe bought
into it was fighting pretty wild i think
it shows his inexperience but now he's
getting a little older fighting smarter
and he's taking these dudes out man
telling he is the real freaking deal man
cell got it done against tim johnson at
heavyweight so that's dope but yeah the
bummer there is the nemkov koreans and
fight you just went on five more seconds
you have a clear winner there
speaking about that so there's two
different fights on the ufc card the
vegas 51 fights
and
because it was past that mid point in
the rounds and the two guys that did the
unintentional fouls one was a
elbow to the back of a head of barnett
and then one was a
knee to a downer down opponent both of
those guys that threw those strikes they
won because it was considered
unintentional and then they went to the
scorecards after that midpoint of the
round
yeah it's a bummer i know dc had he went
off right now oh diddy yeah here let me
show you real quick so this is from
mmania but this guy's winning the fight
the whole time oh yeah but i don't know
how much the scorecards were
that's directly and people are saying
these are intentional they're not
unintentional so if they're intentional
they would just stop the fight the other
guy would win or be no cause go back to
that elbow chin it's tough because if
you touch the ear it's
definitely behind the head
let me see that again
yep didn't touch the air that's
definitely illegal all right yeah so he
won the fight he won the fight okay this
one's a crazier one
but his hand certainly was you'll see
here
it's a bad knee too
[Music]
oof
yeah and they both won their fights so
it's just it feels really really weird
yeah it's tough man
uh no knock on uh
cow or martin cow or martin but every
single time i threw a striking lock down
it was intentional they both should have
been disqualified
so when two rounds throw unintentionally
you'll strike and then hope the guys can
continue so that you all go to the
judges right then [ __ ] you don't run the
risk of losing
yeah if you're up to like slightly up
and the guy's kind of you know
making a comeback just throwing a legal
strike
and this guy's just that man after he
gave you perhaps going to do this what
do you mean
[Music]
i don't know why he even entertains this
just great dc cow was dominating that
fight before he got stopped he deserved
to win my opinion
so speedy on fight one correct
yeah you
yeah it's a problem in our in our
scoring system in the in the judging
there i mean it just because you're up
on the score cards you know let's say
two rounds and you're growing that third
you throw a legal strike it should just
be a no contest dq no matter what no
matter what
that's not the rules so what do you want
you know what are you gonna do yeah
because this leaves an opening for the
rules this leaves an opening for people
like you said like hey i'm winning two
rounds losing a little bit and that's
the last half of it throw an
unintentional strike but you throw an
intentional strike you know you're
assuming the guy can't go on yeah
it'd be tough to pull off i see i see
where it opens up pandora's box there
but it'd be tough i have to pull to
exactly land it so the guy can't go on
you'd have to be really bad
all right so this was pretty crazy
andrew ruiz jr and tyrone spong they're
going to be boxing at trailer that's a
terrible fight for spunk i don't know
how to do this no i thought he lost two
for some reason but he won his last
boxing match
no
this is
wiki
but yeah i feel like he did maybe it was
an exhibition or something no because he
fought homeboy the russian cat
puliv oh [ __ ]
remember so it must have been an
exhibition that's why i saw his record
yeah
are we just off on this i could have
sworn i have this i i thought let's be
honest it's a bad idea oh wait that was
frank mirror right
was it frank mirepole just type in
poolab let's see his record
damn it hold up
kaspang lost a tear keratana off right
yeah but not boxing we're just off on
this let's see
i think because the whole exhibition
stuff it gets tricky
so pool i've lost to joshua
good one for joshua
let me type in frank may real quick
because i remember somebody fought
and mma fought a monster and she got
dealt with
nope stephen steve damn where the hell
did he fight so someone's supposed to
fight puliv right yes so maybe there's a
town was supposed to was it jds
yes that's who it was that's supposed to
fight pull off but you and me for some
reason remember town sprong losing a
boxing match to some honest robots
that's right because i remember being
like that's a terrible idea for spunk
was it maybe it was
or maybe we were saying that because he
fought kirtanov in mma maybe
we just got our russians mixed up
that must be a thing yeah because
keraton of you know
the bad matchup for spunk maybe that's
what we're thinking of yeah yeah
okay but either way either way yeah
he's a son so he's fighting that's a
tough andrew junior birdies is a
monster
in boxing yeah
so july 16th
the sponge have the power to take out
[ __ ] ruiz i mean ruiz is so skilled
compared to spawn sponge just started
really his hands are fast too man yeah
powerful too
all right um
let's start with this one first
all right this is a quick one so caesar
gracie said that nick diaz is likely to
compete by the end of this year
interesting
because remember there's all that talk
that he didn't really want to do it he
had to do it yeah and now he's gonna
fight again and then i heard him he
didn't look you know he looked great for
taking that long of a time off but
i wonder he wasn't in shape or anything
but yeah
yeah fight by the end of the year
interesting i'm never mad when nick
fights ornate hopefully they get
negative fight too i know nate was
kind of advocating that he wants to
fight on the bell toward hawaii card
yeah you know with his boy yancy it yeah
it doesn't matter um but
there was like some sort of weird stuff
going on where it seemed like nick diaz
and some other team didn't like caesar
gracie like because of how he's
putting nick out there just to fight
whatever maybe for the money oh really
so maybe
yeah again saying because his nick said
anything it's just caesar gracie yeah
that's dicey man
but those are just rumors
i don't know the dynamic there yeah
okay so michael bisping if that were to
happen if nick diaz does fight this end
of the year he says you should go for
jorge malzado or donald cerrone
and then he made a thing here about like
if he fought mozi doll
mozart makes more sense you beat up my
little brother exactly let's do it man
obviously i forgot the mazda you know
lawsuit and all that [ __ ]
so he goes here's one that you might
think is crazy but i'd like to see it i
don't think it's crazy mike
um you put this on paper it's gonna
sound like your [ __ ] nate or
nick diaz or jorge mazda there it is bfm
belt on the line once again conover
snake diaz in the main event they have
jorge nick nick diaz there's the master
storyline yeah i agree 100 percent
yeah if you're gonna do that depend what
you wanna do with conor if he's gonna
fight volknovsky or fight for the 155
title of the winner of oliveira gaichi
if conor doesn't want to do that you you
finished conor and nate diaz contract
with them fighting each other yeah
dude that's the main event and they have
nick jorge as the that'd be a massive
cardinal nazos
um and related to bisming jake paul
had recently i guess added him to his
hit list and then michael bisbee
responded to it
uh this is uh him responding first come
on so come on you know
you know i'm about your size surely
excuse me for me hit list that's very
funny
then jake put jake paul put uh i would
knock you out worse than hendo
you're an easy fight but show me you can
get licensed i will show you one million
plus pay-per-view
in the two eye emojis using this emoji
because bisping can't use it
mm-hmm savage these [ __ ] young kids
have no chill
uh biswing i love both these guys man
but yeah yeah listen one eye two eyes i
won a world championship and
here's thing
bisping won a world championship with
one eye
that's how much of a badass is with one
[ __ ] eye he won a world championship
against luke rockhold
who was a late replacement came in luke
rockhold at the time still is but
especially at the time was in his prime
and knocked him out
uh bison put yeah yeah listen one eye
two eyes i won a world championship more
importantly the respect of the fight me
sadly little jakey that's two things
you'll never do ever let that sink in
[Music]
dear bisping i challenge you to stop
posting your struggling
podcast savage i'm telling you these
young kids have no chill dude
i'm also struggling podcast i mean yeah
i guess compared to the paul brothers or
the elk boys and [ __ ]
but you got to realize
it's different
so i think a lot of times people
confuse
how well a podcast does based off their
because there's been this kind of
push or narrative that the youtube
numbers are what decides a successful
podcast
i can't emphasize this enough for people
out there who think that
and your boys a podcast connoisseur
podcast businessman
the the views that you see on youtube
the videos i'm sure for the elk boys and
logan paul and stuff because they from
the youtube world
and you know mr beast or whatever
they're making money on that doing
around they're making all the money more
money than me busy and all this stuff
but when it comes to the podcast world
nothing is more important than audio
numbers audio is king people consume a
podcast
on the audio side
50 times more than the video so whatever
you see if you're gonna base a show
success based off video now if it's only
on video sure judge it based off that
but if it's audio and video there's a
reason why it's on audio the these
podcasts that
you know that you've seen recently get
these
you know crazy deals rogan's which they
have video on there but you know rogan
was much bigger on audio than he was
video on youtube and then uh caller
daddy
much bigger on audio than she was video
that's what she got whatever 60 million
and also armchair expert with dax
shepard he didn't have video
just audio yeah the biggest podcast like
even
because it's only audio audio that's it
audio is king
so you know here's some
putting game on you guys as the podcast
game goes and i tell this to these young
kids all the time coming like i want to
do this
video video i get it you nothing is more
important if you want to make money on a
podcast then your audio your audio is
[ __ ] everything now
the video complements that and adds
value and you get a bigger cpm when you
have both but your cpm based off how
much you get paid per read is based off
your audio and video well they'll mix
them now that combined them but if your
audio is say half your video you're
gonna make less money that's where the
podcast game works
so definitely don't judge a book based
off of their
youtube
views it's just the game doesn't work
like that
but again to jake paul yeah i mean
i
99 of pockets out there are struggling
compared to anything he posts you know
he's just a [ __ ] youtube monster yeah
he put dear brisbane on trying to stop
posting a struggling podcast get
licensed to fight and box me let's see
if that ufc belt i'll respect you have
can help you beat me in a boxing match
uh-huh he says so bisbane's coming at me
on twitter saying i'll never win a
championship i'll never earn the respect
to the fight community he may be right
now you can't can't pay your now you
can't
can't pay your rent or mortgage with
championship build respect so quite
frankly i don't give a [ __ ] funny
when i was crying earlier after he
tweeted me out sobbing i started wiping
tears away with that 50 million i made
fighting last year
these kids no children
uh you know my last fight but by round
three was over i made more money than he
did in his entire career that's probably
a fact too
so i get why he's mad at the new kid on
the block whatever now michael i'm not
the type person to talk [ __ ] without
backing it up so if you can get licensed
with your one eye and old ass and all
that crazy [ __ ] you got going on i would
love to fight you let's see if the
championship that you won all the
respect you have from the fight me can
really get you through a boxing match
with me because i bet it can't i will
whoop your old ass
yeah you know bismi is a little older
and i you know i don't know if business
can entertain that um
you know i i love both guys i love jake
and jake was at the show the other night
and told you guys like he's dead serious
about changing the fighter pay which all
the respect in the world to him
jake does have to be a little careful
you know because if bisping did take
this serious
you know bisping's a different animal
with his footwork and his head movement
like his wings was a [ __ ] man
you'll see legend greatest fighter ever
come out of europe that we've had you
know so especially england represents
england so
um you know visiting his savage you know
i just don't know where bisping's at
physically if he wants to do it his eye
if he can get commission he clearly can
you know he probably could
somewhere
florida i'm sure would do it
uh you know saudi arabia some of those
middle east countries would do it he
could definitely make it happen if
bisping truly wants this fight
if you know bisbee is doing fine
financially you know with with his pods
that he's doing the shows that he's
doing his bts show um you know and then
obviously he's commentated for the ufc
so it's not bizman's not struggling
now is he making jake paul 40 million
dollars no god no so it could be a
really big payday but i would be willing
to bet
um
it would take a lot more than guarantee
him a million dollars to fight him to
get bisping out of bed to do this
a lot more jake
you know
bisbee is one of those few smart guys
who parlayed his fight career into
something much bigger yeah
everybody makes more money now he does
fighting yeah especially commentating
too yeah i don't know what how much they
paint those guys you know i don't
have an idea how much rogan gets but i
have no idea like anik or dc or
felder or dominic cruz i'm not sure i
don't know what dfc pays for
commentating i'm going to guess i have
no clue
but i'm sure bisping's fine is the point
of all this yes it would take a lot more
than a million dollars to get him out of
bed to fight jake paul love to see it
it'd be cool
all right this is a hanzo just posting
on his twitter
this right here which is jesus christ
and then he says let's go so that's
that's colby covington with police
people behind him kobe's on the left
with basically uh just watching right
yes
crew
and then hamzazz on the right with a
bunch of [ __ ] wolves that is a fire
ass poster
holy [ __ ] he said let's go
dude that fight would be nuts i was on
abc
yeah
and check this out this is kind of crazy
but the opening odds so far wait not
that one
here we go
uh the opening on so far is hamza is
actually
he's a minus 125
he's a favorite right now which is
insane but
can we has odds of possible fights since
last year with usman open as a 200
favorite over
hamza um
i'm a betting man
and i told you guys this and
hamza lived up to the hype what he did
to the number two guy in the world after
going into that hype and really learning
the hard way how tough those guys that
the top three the tip of the spirit guys
he learned the hard way yeah he didn't
fight very smart still got it done
complete badass
only caveat to that and i'm a betting
man if those odds if this fight comes
fruition
the odds are like that i would probably
put money on coven colby
yeah like right now like right now yeah
that being said if hamzat and his he is
one of the best teams in the world as
coach even goes dude what are you doing
there should be a much easier fight i
agree it should have been easier fight
with his skill set and length and you
know reach and all that should have been
much easier to fight but he felt like he
had to entertain the fans and make it
this you know
this war which i don't think he needed
to do and shout out to gilbert byrne
shows us how [ __ ] great he is
but and again i'm a and i ge i would
guarantee he's learned from that so this
is besides the point but
if he fought that night against a guy
like kobe or camaro he would not have
won
he was very lucky he learned of that a
priceless lesson to be entertaining and
still be able to win a fight like that
by decision very valuable lesson
priceless lesson for him in his young
ufc career
because again if they would have thrown
him
too much gave him a colby or camaro
you know he was a loss on his record and
the hype kind of goes away you see what
they did you know the same thing
happened there until so much so much
hype with till
they give him [ __ ] woodley man in his
hometown it's just too much too soon
now if you wait three or four fights you
let till learn from experience in the
ufc because again i don't give a flying
[ __ ] what you did outside the ufc you
see's a completely different animal it's
a [ __ ] savage business
so i think if you could redo darren
till's career and you let him warm up
man you give him some better fights
better matchups toss them up you know a
good opponent here and you slowly bring
him up
darren telling izzy would already fought
by now
do i think he beats is he right now no
but still
a better chance and we're not talking
about that anymore you know so i think
you know you learn from darren till and
you know it was too much too soon he
learned the [ __ ] the hardest way it's
a shame and ruins the guy's confidence
so for hamza you know i think is just
the most priceless lesson he could ever
ever learn i guarantee you when he
fights colby on abc if they figure i'd
deal with kobe he's not gonna be sitting
on the cage chilling like it's a [ __ ]
happy hour on a friday guarantee he does
it you're gonna see a different hamza
he's gonna be ready for war
and not that weird you know stay in the
pocket getting hit with shots it's gonna
be you know it's gonna take and even if
he
learns from that fight it's still a
tough fight for him yeah don't get it
twisted kobe is a mother [ __ ]
you know i know nobody likes his
antics and all that [ __ ] but
kobe's the baddest welterweight on the
planet not named kamar usman
he goes camaro colby hamza
that's how this goes
but you know i can't wait for that fight
yeah i hope it happens that post is
[ __ ] dope i know
uh we kind of expected this but marlon
rise officially retires what a great
fighter man yeah great career
you know champion i think over that
world series of fighting
as you ufc created some great wins you
know it's tough too uh he goes i want to
thank everyone sean show with dana white
ufc for giving me so many opportunities
i think my family my coach manager
everyone who has been around been part
of my career thank you to mark henry
ricardo almeida frankie edgar
uh anderson franco hunter campbell i'm
still gonna be around the sport helping
uh young guys and help my friends
did he have so many fights keep going
down
he turned pro in 2007 dude jeez
wool series a fighting champion
uh after a certain deal with ufc
marlin suffered a razor close split
decision loss since debut and then
bounced back with four straight wins
including knockouts over futur future
bantamweight champion al james
sterling's insane knockout jimmy rivera
who's no punk world series [ __ ]
champion as well
um uh
he avenged his first ufc loss with
submission win over asante al which is
nuts
which then led to his opportunity to
become banned weight champion and fight
he had a successful career man either
way he painted i had a championship
fight against henderson hudo that's
where cejudo broke him i think he's
never the same after that yeah
his last five appearances ufc marlon
went one for the win over jose aldo
which people thought he lost
uh they lost to corey sanhagen which was
an insane fight rob from rob front
he always fought the best of the best in
the ufc is a successful career but yeah
no matter how you paint that thing i
know he's it's tough to have perspective
he might have it maybe now he's retired
or it might take a few years
you know because i'm sure his goal when
he had the ucsb ufc champion since
didn't achieve that maybe he feels a
type of way about his career but dude
what a career bubba congratulations man
only were you a world series
chip world champion which is not easy to
do
you were dominant over there and came to
the ufc and fought the who's who dude
you've beat the current champion
you know yeah he has to be jose aldo
okay did i think he won that fight by
the judges but to the scorecards no but
doesn't matter history book show you be
[ __ ] jose aldo
all right and another guy not he's not
um retiring but he's no longer the uc
cowboy oliver very exciting guy but yeah
you see deciding not to four straight on
his contract yeah four straight to
business man unfortunate
um fun fighter to watch though yeah
11 and 10
with one note contest
um this one here
so
john mccarthy at al james jones have
been going back and forth oh really yeah
yikes so
let's just start with this one
this is john
talking about how he was impressed with
algerman but he didn't there's no way
that he won that first round
yeah but then he there's more to it he
kind of changes the story after a while
all right so he goes i was very here's
the thing when big john speaks
you know it holds so much more
weight than if i do or
bisping or luke thomas or chael sonnen
the guy wrote the rule books so you
gotta kind of take it that into
consideration so let's see what he says
there but again he's not a judge anymore
he's not i'm sorry he's not a ref
anymore grace to ever do it big john's
the best
he's retired right he does a podcast
with josh thompson great pod called
wayne in love those guys they're some of
the best
but remember too now john's in this
weird lane of entertainment too so let's
see what he says there i was very
impressed with al jamaine the way he
fought but there's no way he won that
first round
uh the heavier shots were landed easily
by yon
and i thought it was a smart tactic by
alderman to stay outside to move
continuously but he didn't land much he
landed more than yawn dude
that's just numbers
literally just the number i'm not i'm
not trying to disagree with big john
because i have no right to do that but
i'm just going off the numbers
uh he landed a couple of kicks not real
hard
doesn't matter dude those are still what
shots landed he got hit with some heavy
shots for a little bit and right near
then john really started landing some
good shots but didn't land more shots
big john
there's no way in the world you tell me
that algo won the first round
man knowing the world he thinks it was
that decisive
for now this is the entertainer big john
come out but i will say though he fought
a great fight secretary being the the
one this is the difference he won the
second round huge
now he did not damage yon so i i i can
see why they all went 10-9 with it but
it was the clearest round of all them
easily for algae the third round was
pretty similar bubba so if you're taking
a look at it the first round close
fourth round fifth round close
but peter young wins them
second
second third round easy for al germain
so i'm not upset with him winning the
fight i thought he actually fought a
very smart fight fought well and he
forgot to give props he won the belt the
way it's supposed to be one
i'll jermaine so this is al jamaine
going off on john after that this is on
aerial show too santa here all right
shout out to ariel you put for people to
say there's absolutely no way you could
scroll that round big stupid uh you got
dang it al jermaine don't
go show respect alger man there's better
ways to do this
you know what the thing is though is
that al jamaine is young and he's also
like
you know he hits so much [ __ ] yeah he's
clear beyond fighting and then also and
i told you you know the headlines uh
brendan shaw brips dana white apart no i
didn't i just don't agree with devaluing
your product your champion because when
you say that again
it carries so much more more weight than
big john me chael luke thomas bisping
anybody in the space
it carries so much weight when your own
boss who
is in charge of your career the path
that it takes goes he didn't win that
fight
what
why would you say that
nobody's gonna consider the real champ
he went out there and [ __ ] worked his
ass off man
even if you believe that you're just as
far as a business move it just doesn't
make sense because now he has to fight
tj dillashaw and the narrative he's not
in real champ we're not going to buy
that
that affects your bottom dollar
really espn's because you're getting
paid no matter what so i get you can
just fly by see your pants but still
it's there's no upside to it at all
at all
it makes no sense to me
so here's al jermaine responded big john
for people to say there's absolutely no
way you could score that round big
stupid john mccarthy
dude go get a clue
he wrote the rule book dude uh i don't
know how this guy was ever the blueprint
standard of mma because this guy sucks
his opinion stinks and it's and it sucks
he just he just says [ __ ] i think he
just wants people to think that he knows
what he's talking about he doesn't know
what he's talking about jermaine and i
love you dude but i think he had an mma
school i think he had fighters which one
of them
ever did anything which one of them he
should it should and did
did any of them do anything he should
say here uh what did a school ever do
clearly this guy's so great right so
what has he ever accomplished
other than trying to judge people and
being completely wrong about the scoring
criteria of the fight
if you want to have an opinion having a
pin john but doesn't mean you're correct
you're not going by the criteria of how
you score a fight please just be quiet
and let the big boys do
uh at a high level something you've
never accomplished
and then
josh thompson went at him
uh why didn't funk master have the same
energy with dana white said he lost to
fight a uh big john i'll wait
yeah i yeah bulls because that's his
boss right yeah
um i have then some guy put um i have
sitting on my couching orders experience
that beats big john's
exact exactly just like funk master may
i'll make a bet he doesn't know all the
rules to make so how is he going to tell
someone like big john she doesn't know
what he's talking about asking for a
friend
how's your man put josh respectfully get
the [ __ ] out of my nuts you and john can
go
these young kids are savages yeah
savages
get the [ __ ] off my nuts you and john
can go below each other in the back
studio for all i care you guys
constantly dog me for ratings piss off
already
ftr what's that thing for the record for
the record i shoot on dance paint too i
have a shitty day
and then uh this guy he didn't have to
wait long on that one it was this dude
don't stop any chance for some clicks
him and fatty
[ __ ] sakes dude just so disrespectful
this dude don't stop any chance from
clicked him and fatty talks about me or
throw shade like what have you done so
great to feel comfortable talking to you
about another fighter that are actually
doing it him of all people should
respect that i should have been checking
jm
i don't know then
yeah
yeah yeah i mean i i don't agree with
big john
uh and then big john replied
all right uh funk master mma i see that
what i say cause you great distress the
fact that i don't agree on a single
round should not affect or impact your
life in any way i said you fought a
great fight and you did congrats name
colin really champions are above that
agree
by the way jam means just messing
gotcha all right and then this is john
after all this
big john spoke about weighing in podcast
once again i wasn't even going to talk
about i'm being honest when i'm saying
this al jermaine may not like me i don't
care you can like me or okay if you're
thinking i have anything against him
um i don't i think he's a great fighter
he's talented he's fun to watch
continuing big john said i'll be honest
i went back and watched the first round
that's what i'm saying dude you gotta go
back and watch the first round before
you chime in everybody
and that goes to you dana out of
everybody you gotta you gotta wait after
the press conference all right let me
check this out then maybe the next one
talk about it so you have a legit
educated opinion because you sit in cage
side at that little shitty screen and
whatever you're doing there that's not
gonna work for me dude you have too much
power man so he put i'll be honest i
went back and watched the first round
i'll say this
uh i say this all time don't sit there
and talk to your friends and watch a
fight and think you judge it correctly
correct
that's why that's why when we do the
fighting pants it's where i get my
honest opinion i'm drinking sucking
[ __ ] vaping you know i don't know
what i'm doing [ __ ] [ __ ] so i go back
and watch i'm bubbling with the boys i
go back and watch it sunday yeah yeah i
gotta watch it by my side wait do the
kids go to bed or i wake up before them
and i watch it before i jump on this
show and give you an honest opinion
because otherwise this can i'm gonna be
completely off and i'm a guy i don't
back down so then i gotta ride with this
terrible opinion
like dana
uh you put i'll be honest i went back
and watch the first round i say this all
the time don't sit there and talk to
your friends and watch a fight and think
you judged it correctly because i was
talking to my friends and i went back
and watched it as a judge it's razor
close it can go either way i can
understand where some uh someone looked
at al joe and gives him the round i can
see where yes yon won the round
john went on to discuss the fight legit
uh logistics and judge who scored it
fish with i'm not going to watch a fight
with friends anymore my previous comment
was wrong i learned a lesson my
statement was wrong i could have gone
either way it was that damn close if you
look at the fight as a whole i thought
al germain won
and that validates your boy's opinion
that's all we
need suck it [ __ ] it
all right enough of them get on big john
though he's a grown man with experience
he can admit when he's wrong there's
nothing wrong with it i like it when
people met with their own me too it's
human that's what we should do
open-minded man but yeah if you're
especially of a fight at that caliber
that high of a level if you're there
with your friends you're [ __ ] eating
pizza talking about whatever [ __ ]
and you know you're looking at your
friend oh waiting for the big moments
that you don't have the perspective to
chime in and go i think john won what
you're just talking to me about your
[ __ ]
whatever dad's talking about they're
your lawn dude for [ __ ] 30 minutes we
missed two rounds and you're gonna chime
in that yawn one okay
what else you got all right
this right here uh so this dude shafka
rakmonov is a killer
so he's 15-0 real problem all finishes
real pro real problem and of course of
all people neil magney's going to fight
him
do not like neil calls up pretty much
the craziest guys like hamza and now
he's going to fight one enough he was
identified hamza yeah he's like one of
the only guys that kept calling him out
did not like that fight for neil you'd
be tough i don't like this fight either
yeah
but uh yeah he's a badass
and that's june 25th fight night
that guy is a monster
oh i love this main event yeah full call
versus rosenstein hell yeah five rounds
mm-hmm
and um needs to win that one so this
this is a fork in the road for both
these gentlemen yeah volkavasi just lost
to aspinal
i think they do asthma all versus tied
to avasa
i can see that happen in the summer
that could be on uh stipe jones car damn
big boy i like both those guys too yeah
i love both of them it would be a fun
fight
i think this is the last one
it's official that uh well it's pretty
much official that we already knew this
martin ford versus that iranian hulk
they're supposed to box each other yeah
it's off now and then martin ford says
this same picture speaks a thousand
words let's just say what uh turned up
was not what was sold to us by the
investors this followed up by crying on
tv and saying that he wants to end his
life was enough for us concerns on
mental well-being and also health and
safety risks involved with this matchup
but apparently that guy even though he
went on tv crying saying his parents
disowned him he also says he's going to
sue them if the fight doesn't continue
because he still wants to fight but he
would get destroyed
and this is just uh martin ford on his
facebook answering questions daniel
canahan is amazing but why is the fight
not going ahead you know daniel kinihan
is that
he's like uh they're looking for him now
right well he's not allowed in the u.s
yeah there's a five-minute run like bond
form yeah yeah cartel like right irish
cartel but he's also a boxing promoter
and he still has relationships with all
these people yeah with a lot of people
working with tyson
till they tell us pictures with him and
[ __ ] a lot of people that one fighter
got in the mic on [ __ ] saturday night
yeah gave him a shout out he's like i
don't know what he does then when they
ask him he's like i don't know what he
does yeah it's just he's a good friend
and an advisor
but uh yeah so basically we already knew
this but
yeah that guy's not the same guy
the state bigger speaker thunderman
let's just say what tournament was that
look at that i know
so lame yeah yeah remember was it last
week i was like hey ford it ain't
happening i'll tell you that right now
this guy's looking for every way out
is that it that's it for current events
fun show man uh you have ufc fight night
this weekend the ufc is
they're edging us man their edges before
we get another big event yeah limo's
versus just gondrodge not matt that main
event uh tanner bozer uh romanov is fun
clay guida's back at it macy barber's
always fun steve garcia's cool
favorite fire in the card tyson pedro
who's a big favorite over uh
villanova
um but pedro's back he's had some
injuries he's back he's one of my faves
to watch wish he was on the main card
disrespectful he's not but either way
you can watch him on the prelims on the
aspen plus
not a great card no
and then there's uh belt or two you know
it's whatever the best fight of the
the weekend is uh in boxing you had
tyson fury verstilian white that's a
great [ __ ] fight yeah
and it's been weird too because dylan
white didn't show up to the press
conference he pulled the old tyson fury
move on him he doesn't want to you know
do that so just fury is a minus 550 on
draftkings uh doing white plus 400 be a
tough fight for for dillian white yeah
and also
you guys know this pretty biased type
sphere is my favorite fighter in combat
sports so
suck it
uh that's it man i will have the tyson
fury fight on in the green room at the
paramount theater this mother truck and
saturday it is one show only
at the moon tower comedy festival this
saturday paramount theater biggest
theater your boy's ever done besides my
special at the spreckels in san diego
but pair out there is a big one for
austin so come on out austin your boy
needs you now more than ever moon tower
comedy festival your boy's headlining
the paramount theater it's a real big
feather in your boy's cap schultz shot
is special there rogan's performed there
whitney cummings the who's who have
performed at paramount it's a historical
theater it's an honor to headline that
theater it's saturday night the thick
boy crew will be in effect baby that's
this saturday austin texas one show only
get tickets right now at fatkz.com or
thickboy.com then wednesday night before
i head to austin
wednesday night shop and friends it'd be
our
eighth or ninth sell out this year once
you're only at 8pm at the hollywood
improv i have an extremely special guest
for you guys
but i can't announce his name but it's
an extremely
to me top three goats right now doing
stand-up comedy you also got freaking uh
giannis papa's is on there you got david
lucas you got freaking uh michael
rappaport myself it's gonna be a
phenomenal show man that is one show
only at eight p.m it will sell out so if
you're listening this right now go get
your mother trucking tickets la that's
hollywood improv this wednesday at 8 p.m
with a hell of a lineup and then austin
texas saturday then after that may 5th
through the 7th is charlotte north
carolina at the comedy zone out there
come get some charlotte and then philly
one of my favorite cities in the world
philadelphia is may 19th through the
21st at the helium out there in the
philadelphia area
um and then the special drops april 28th
on thick boy youtube man been a long
time coming
i think you guys can be proud of your
boy man it's the best it's the best i
can do how about that and i've put in
some goddamn work to give you 30 minutes
of [ __ ] fury man
it's uh called the gringo poppy and that
will uh release april 28th
on thick boy youtube
i'm taking matters my own hands man you
know i had offers from every major
network you can imagine i met with them
got the offers thought about it and said
my team can pull this off we can do this
you'll see billboards around that la
austin new york
you'll see all the sizzle all that stuff
i think we can do it you'll see me do
the pr tour on all your favorite
podcasts we're going to blow this thing
out so april 28th big day for your boy
man i'm super proud of it hopefully you
guys are too that's on thick boy youtube
april 28th man i can't wait but austin
see you this saturday paramount theater
love you guys thank you for subscribing
liking watching whatever you do man oh
we just also dropped the first feature
off the thick boy album which also drops
april 28th with little brows
um it's called standing ovation with
mike stud there's a uh music video on
think boy right now little brows is so
goddamn talented uh basically the suge
knight of the music podcast game but i'm
not all up in the videos but i am in
this video i had to because mike said i
couldn't come to l.a so we had readjust
things and uh at the lip sync for him
and that was a nightmare i had literally
45 minutes to learn the lyrics so you'll
see me trying to flub those words so
that's fun um but i'm so proud of this
album my only
goal with this is for little brows to
blow up so big that he doesn't have to
work anymore because he's that talent
he's that good of a human being that's
why i support him and do all this you
know all this collab stuff with him but
on the album you'll see dude you got
chin worked on it you got krista lee on
there mike stud jelly roll bert
kreischer chappelle
mark harley's on there you got a crew
man yeah and there's some bangers
they'll think my album is [ __ ] great
man and that drops april 21st but the
first feature just dropped on itunes
spotify apple music amazon
um it's the song if you've been any tour
my song i walked out to on stage so uh
enjoy it's available right now little
browse mike stud stand ovation but again
austin i'll see you this saturday
paramount theater come on out for your
boy tickets at thinkboy.com or fatkz.com
that's it man love you guys till next
time stay thick stay safe i'm out